Des vidéos de bagarre comme celle-ci,
j'en ai vu défiler plusieurs
sur des comptes Instagram
ou Telegram.
J'ai contacté
la plupart de ces comptes
pour comprendre ce phénomène de combat de rue
et pourquoi les personnes qui tiennent ces comptes
les mettaient en ligne.
Tous ont refusé de me rencontrer pour une interview.
Seule une personne a accepté de me répondre
par téléphone
et de manière anonyme.
Ça me paraît important de mettre en garde
sur les dangers de tels contenus.
Et c'est pour ça
que dans cette vidéo,
j’ai décidé de vous parler
de l'histoire d’Aymane.
Aymane, c'est un
jeune boxeur de quinze ans
qui vivait à Bondy,
et après plusieurs bagarres
et des altercations filmées,
il est tué par le grand frère
d'un de ses amis
en février 2021.
Avec Hugo Baiardi,
on a essayé de retracer
l'escalade de la violence
qui a mené à la mort d‘Aymane.
Un peu plus.
Plus.
Coude.
La première fois que j'ai rencontré Aymane,
c'était à un forum des associations.
Je lui ai mis
une paire de gants
et il a tapé un peu dans mes pattes d’ours
et il a eu un déclic.
Je lui avait dit :
“Si t'es sérieux, bah, je te mettrai en compétition.
Si tu travailles bien.”
Et puis dès le début,
il m’avait dit : “Coach, je veux faire de la compétition.
Je veux faire de la compétition.
Je veux...
Je veux être champion du monde.”
Sa première compétition,
c'étaient les championnats
d'Île-de-France.
Ça faisait pas très longtemps
qu’il faisait de la boxe.
J'ai vu Aymane
commencer à faire
son combat
et j'ai dit : “Oh,
il a faim. Il en veut, quoi.”
Il en prenait, mais il avançait.
Et ils ont levé le bras
d’Aymane.
Waouh. Ça m’a fait... ici dans le cœur, ça m’a fait...
ça m'a fait tout bizarre.
Et après, je
regardais sa grand-mère,
je regardais ses parents qui pleuraient, qui étaient...
son papa qui était
vachement fier.
Qui était même...
étonné de voir son fils
champion d'Île-de-France.
Je ne vous cache pas que j'ai pleuré, quoi.
Quand il a gagné la médaille, la médaille d’or
et il s'est qualifié pour les championnats de France.
C'est toujours...
Même nous, il nous dit :
“Un jour je serai champion,
je serai champion, quoi.”
Il m'a demandé de lui
acheter pas mal de trucs
pour faire la boxe,
même à la maison,
pour l'entraîner, tout ça, quoi.
Et là, j'ai compris que,
franchement,
il est dedans, quoi.
Ça, c’est ses affaires de boxe.
On va les ranger ici.
Ça c’est...
On le laisse ici, mais...
Ouais.
Il a acheté ça et...
il a fait deux entraînements avec, pas plus.
On va la mettre ici.
Franchement, il était adorable, quoi.
Il était plein d'énergie, quoi.
C'était comme un turbo, quoi.
Il joue, il bouge
et il fait des blagues,
même à la maison.
C'est comme lui, l'acteur, quoi.
C'était toujours son but,
c’est d'attirer l'attention
vers lui, quoi.
À force de gagner
des combats de boxe thaï,
il prend confiance
et il lui arrive
de participer à des combats de rue filmés.
Et ça, ses parents et ses proches n'en savaient rien.
Dans ces vidéos,
on voit Aymane
et d'autres jeunes se battre.
J’ai jamais entendu parler
de ces combats sauvages.
Moi-même, si j'avais été au courant, je serais intervenu.
C'est du n'importe quoi
parce que
sur un ring, il y a un arbitre,
il y a des règles,
il y a des codes, des valeurs.
Là, c’est...
C'est tout l'inverse
de ce qu'on leur apprend.
On salue !
Tout d'abord, bonjour à tous,
merci d'être au rendez-vous.
Franchement, ça fait
plaisir de vous revoir. C’est...
Je pense que moi
et puis les coachs,
ça nous fait énormément plaisir.
Tout le monde sait ce qui s'est passé avec Aymane ?
Oui !
Voilà. Bon, je trouve
pas les mots, mais bon.
Ça nous a beaucoup touchés parce que c'est...
c’est un membre, on va dire, de notre famille.
Un jour, Aymane propose à un de ses amis,
qu'on appellera “Sofiane”,
de le suivre au club.
“Sofiane” a deux ans
de plus qu’Aymane
et il commence à prendre des cours de boxe thaï, lui aussi.
À la base,
ils s'entendaient bien.
C'étaient des bons copains
et ils faisaient
toutes leurs sorties ensemble
et après, du jour au lendemain, bah...
il y a eu le problème, l’altercation à la boxe,
et c'est parti de là.
C'est ce qu'il m'avait dit :
”Ouais, là, j’ai tapé.
On s'amusait à taper
de plus en plus fort.
Je lui ai fait mal.
Il a mal pris la chose.”
Quand il y a des rivalités
entre élèves
et que ça se passe pendant l'entraînement...
Doucement ! Eh !
Top ! Top ! Eh !
C’est quoi ça ?
On va prendre les deux élèves, on les amène à soi
et puis, en général, je leur dis : “Stop, on n'en parle plus.”
Il y a eu peut-être un échange
où il a tapé un peu plus fort.
Et puis, après la boxe, ils se chamaillent là-dessus,
ils se chambrent.
Et puis après, derrière,
il y a les réseaux sociaux,
les gens filment
et puis ça attise la violence.
Les bagarres qui les opposent
sont filmées et
partagées à Bondy
et le grand frère de “Sofiane”
finit par s'en mêler.
La première altercation,
je sais qu’elle était ici.
Son frère, il est venu
devant le gymnase,
il a voulu régler ses comptes.
Le grand, là,
il est venu voir Aymane
et en fait,
pour défendre son frère,
et il y avait des adultes à côté, autour de lui,
et en fait, Aymane,
il a tapé le grand frère, quoi.
Il a tapé le grand frère
de 27 ans
et lui, il l'a pas accepté.
Un trafiquant de drogue,
qui se présente
comme un patron,
machin, tout ça,
comme un grand...
Il l'a tapé devant
les adultes,
pour lui, c’était la honte, quoi.
Il voulait tenir
sa réputation de...
“Voilà, je fais peur,
je suis quelqu'un, quoi.”
Il était au Palais
des sports, il est sorti.
Ils l'ont appelé, ils lui ont dit : “Viens,
on va parler
comme des adultes.”
Et en fait, ils l’ont pris
dans un coin,
ils ont pris un extincteur
et ils ont commencé à le taper.
Ils lui ont ouvert
la tête ici, quoi.
Il m'a dit : “Papa, papa,
j'ai la tête ouverte.”
J’ai dit :
“Qu'est-ce qui t’est arrivé ?”
Il m'a dit : “Je suis tombé.”
Je lui ai dit : “Tu es sûr de toi ?
À quinze ans,  1m82,
tu tombes
comme un enfant ?”
Il m’a dit : “Oui, oui,
je suis tombé.”
Je lui ai dit : “Écoute, je ne comprends pas cette histoire.
Il y a quelque chose derrière, je pense.”
Après, il ne
voulait pas me parler.
Moi, je voulais pas
briser cette confiance de :
“Tu me dis quelque chose,
moi, je le répète
à tes parents.”
Il attendait pas grand-chose des adultes.
Il aimait bien raconter
ce qui s'est passé,
sa journée ou quoi,
mais il ne voulait pas
qu'on intervienne pour lui.
Il aimait bien
se débrouiller tout seul.
Je lui ai dit : “Aymane, t'as menti, tu n'as pas dit la vérité.”
Il a compris
et quand il a parlé, j'ai dit : “OK,
et maintenant,
la solution, c'est quoi ?
Ils t’ont tapé une fois, deux fois. Ils t’ont ouvert la tête.
Troisième ?
C'est quoi la solution ?”
Aymane, il avait peur
que son père
aille au commissariat directement.
C'est pour ça... Voilà, nous,
dans nos quartiers...
on a un peu ce truc de :
“Ah mais vas-y, t’façon, t’es une balance, toi.
Tu vas aller voir les schmitts.”
Ce genre de codes, voilà,
ce genre de réflexions.
Il n'y a pas un jeune que
tu vas voir, à qui tu vas dire :
”Ouais, lui, il t’a tapé,
est-ce que tu vas aller
porter plainte ?”,
il y en a aucun qui va te dire :
“Ouais, je vais aller
porter plainte.” Aucun.
Le 26 février 2021,
c'est les vacances scolaires
et comme à son habitude,
Aymane rejoint ses amis au centre d'animation de la ville.
La directrice, elle m'appelle, elle me dit : “M. Kaïd ?”
Je me dis : “Ah,
si la directrice, elle m’appelle,
ça veut dire qu’Aymane, il a quelque chose, quoi.”
Parce qu'elle ne m'appelle
pas souvent, quoi.
Je lui ai répondu, je lui ai dit : “Qu'est-ce qu’il se passe ?”
Elle me dit : “Il y a rien de grave, il y a rien de méchant.
Vous inquiétez pas.
Juste pour vous dire qu’Aymane,
il y a deux personnes
qui l'ont tapé.”
Et je dis : “C’est qui les deux personnes ?
Les deux personnes,
c’est qui ?”
Et là, elle m'a parlé et j'ai dit : “J’ai compris.”
Et en fait,
c’étaient les deux mêmes.
J'ai vu l'altercation
d’Aymane,
la bagarre,
Aymane qui tenait le grand...
Quand je suis rentré,
au centre,
Aymane, il avait le visage rouge, quoi.
Il avait peur ou... Je sais pas.
J’ai senti qu'il y a un truc qui ne va pas.
Je lui ai dit :
”Aymane, qu'est-ce que
tu penses ?”
Et devant la directrice et les autres, je lui dis :
”On va régler cette histoire.
Soit on va parler aux parents,
comme toi,
tu connais la maman,
soit on va à la police.”
J'ai dit : “Qu’est-ce que
tu penses ?
On va aller voir la maman ?
Tu connais la maman ?
Il m'a dit oui.
Bah, c’est allé vite.
T’as les jeunes qui étaient
devant la porte :
”Ouais, y a nanani.”
Le papa, il est sorti.
Il a vu “Sofiane” avec une barre en métal dans les mains.
Voilà, le papa, il était plutôt dans le contexte
d'aller discuter avec lui.
Son frère, il a 27 ans.
Dans ma tête,
27 ans, c'est un homme.
On peut parler,
on peut discuter,
on peut trouver une solution.
On peut régler l'histoire
entre adultes.
Aymane, il a commencé
à s'approcher
et l’autre, il a pris
une barre de ferraille
et il essayait de le taper, quoi.
Et là, je suis intervenu.
Et après, il y avait...
une bagarre entre nous, pendant...
même pas deux petites minutes, quoi.
Après, voila,
c’est allé super vite.
Moi, j'étais avec les jeunes de mon côté,
en train de leur demander
de rentrer chez eux
parce qu'ils n'avaient pas
à voir tout ça.
Du coup, au moment où je suis revenu,
ils étaient beaucoup
plus loin dans la rue
et ils étaient encore
en pleine altercation.
Voilà, moi, je suis arrivé
en courant.
T’as le grand qui a dit :
“Eh, je reviens dans cinq minutes, bougez pas.”
Et voilà.
Ensuite, bah,
j'étais avec Aymane
et j'étais en train de discuter avec lui.
J'étais en train de lui dire :
“Eh, c'est quoi cette histoire ?
Ça en est venu aux mains avec ton père et tout.”
Je dis : “Voilà, on devrait rentrer dans la structure.
Attendez que ça se repose
un peu, tout ça.”
Et la directrice, elle a dit :
“Il faut bien fermer la porte, quoi?”
Et moi, j'étais avec mon fils, face à face, en train de parler.
Il m'a dit : “Papa...”
Il m'a dit ça. Et ça,
je ne l’oublie pas.
Il m'a dit : “Il est capable de
tirer sur nous.”
Et il me l'a dit comme ça.
J'avais mon collègue, Mamadou, qui était à gauche.
Moi, j'étais à droite.
Aymane, il était en face avec son père et le stagiaire.
On a entendu le bruit
sur la porte, quoi.
C'est comme quelqu'un
qui a essayé de tirer la porte,
d'ouvrir la porte.
Et la directrice, elle a dit :
”Si c’est lui, il ne faut pas
ouvrir la porte.”
Il a mis le pistolet sur la fente de la boîte aux lettres, là.
Il a tiré un coup et...
il a touché directement mon fils au thorax, quoi.
On a entendu la détonation,
voilà, on a vu de la poudre,
de la fumée blanche.
Il y avait l'odeur.
Au début, voilà, j'étais
en train de crier :
“Calmez-vous ! Calmez-vous ! C'est à blanc et tout”, voilà.
Parce que j'avais jamais vu...
Je n'avais jamais eu affaire
à une vraie arme.
Je me suis dit que c'est impossible qu'un...
qu'un adulte, il va tirer
sur un enfant, quoi.
Impossible.
Ce n'était pas
un scénario envisageable.
Quand j'ai vu mon fils,
il n'a pas parlé. Il n’a rien dit.
J'ai dit : “Peut-être c’est des balles à blanc
pour tourner des films
ou pour jouer, tout ça, quoi.”
Et j'ai dit à Samir :
“Tu penses que c'est des balles à blanc ?
Parce que je vois rien,
là, le truc.”
Et, voilà. Après,
on voit Aymane,
un peu plus loin,
retirer sa doudoune,
sa sacoche,
se poser lentement au sol.
Et mon fils, il m'a dit :
“Papa, papa, j'ai mal.”
Moi, j’ai enlevé la veste.
J'ai enlevé le T-shirt
et j'ai vu qu'il y avait
sur le thorax, côté gauche,
là, il y avait...
il y avait la trace
de la balle, quoi.
J'essayais de le faire parler.
Voilà, je lui ai dis
de rester avec moi, quoi.
Je n'avais jamais eu affaire
à ce genre de scénario
et jamais je me suis dit
que ça allait arriver.
Du coup, j'ai procédé un peu comme dans les films :
“Ouais, reste avec moi,
serre-moi la main, parle-moi.”
J'ai essayé tout ce que mon cerveau m’a dit de faire, quoi.
Ahmed, le papa d’Aymane, m'appelle en catastrophe
et j'entendais pas trop.
Parce que c’était brouillé.
Il y avait du bruit autour de lui.
Et puis : “Aymane, Aymane,
il est par terre, il est tombé.”
Et puis après, il me dit :
“Bon, écoute, je te laisse,
je suis avec le SAMU,
la police, les pompiers.”
J'ai envoyé un message :
“Tiens-moi au courant de
l'état de santé d’Aymane,
s’il te plaît.
J'espère que tout
va rentrer dans l'ordre.
Chris.”
Quand j'ai touché le visage
avec la main droite,
il était froid, froid, quoi.
Ouais, et après, je lui ai parlé,
je lui ai parlé
et j'ai vu qu'il répondait pas.
Après, c'est bon, quoi.
Surtout quand le médecin,
il m'a dit...
il m'a dit :
“Il y a plein de sang
à l'intérieur.
Hémorragie interne.
Il n'arrive plus à respirer.”
J'ai compris que
c'était trop tard, quoi.
Ouais.
Il m'a répondu à 20h47 :
“Il est parti, Aymane.
Il ne reviendra plus.”
Aujourd'hui, l'instruction
est toujours en cours
et “Sofiane” et son grand frère
sont en détention provisoire.
Aymane, il est parti, il est parti pour nous, hein.
Ça fait très mal, quoi.
C'est bizarre. Même
quand on rentre à la maison,
des fois, j'ai...
Franchement,
j'ai vu sa maman
derrière la fenêtre,
elle regarde.
C'est ça.
C'est comme la dernière fois, je l'ai entendue, elle a dit...
Parce qu'elle était en train de parler avec sa copine.
Elle a dit : “J'attends Aymane,
qu’il rentre, quoi.”
C'est ça.
C'est bizarre.
Je sais qu'il n'est plus là,
mais dans un coin de ma tête,
je me dis : “Bah...
il est encore là, quoi.”
J’essaye de...
de ne pas y penser.
Voilà, il y a des fois
où ça reste,
il y a des fois
où ça part.
Mais c'est compliqué
à chasser,
ces idées-là de la tête.
Là, j'ai deux jeunes qui...
qui ont du mal.
- C’est compliqué, un peu.
C’est dur.
C'était important pour moi
de vous raconter
l'histoire d'Aymane
et comment des vidéos de bagarre
qui se retrouvent sur Instagram
ou des messageries
peuvent amener à un drame.
Si ce reportage
vous a intéressé,
laissez-moi des commentaires, j’y répondrai
et si vous voulez voir
d'autres reportages,
d'autres documentaires, c'est
sur la page YouTube de Brut.
À bientôt.